[Musica]
7 del mattino sono la sveglia
sembrava a tutti gli effetti essere una
giornata come le altre doccia cappuccino
cornetto mi dirigo verso l'azienda
pensando all'organizzazione della serata
per vedere la partita della Roma con gli
amici
Davide vino il nostro zio Era proprio lì
davanti all'ingresso che mi aspettava
con un mezzo sorriso tra l'entusiasta e
il preoccupato e mi chiedo tra me è
calla Adesso arriva l'attività che mi
stravolgerei i piani della serata beh
avevo torto l'attività era un progetto i
piani della serata erano i piani dei
miei prossimi tre anni di vita Vale non
ci crederai mai siamo stati selezionati
da NASA per partecipare alla missione
d'arte la prima missione di difesa
planetaria conoscevo la missione d'arte
d'arte è una missione unica nel suo
genere allo scopo principale di
impattare un asteroide in particolare di
morfos la luna di un asteroide più
grande di dimos l'impatto sarebbe
avvenuto a circa 11 milioni di
chilometri da Terra nello spazio
profondo e avrebbe accelerato la luna la
velocità con cui ruota attorno a didimos
per modificarne le caratteristiche
orbitali e quindi deflettere la
traiettoria dell'intero sistema ora vi
rassicuro subito il sistema di asteroidi
preso come target della missione d'arte
non è mai stato una reale minaccia con
terra
infatti la missione d'arte è puramente
dimostrativa
e Atta a verificare la fattibilità e la
capacità di utilizzare un impatto
cinematico per deviare e reali minacce
di potenziali impatti col nostro pianeta
per far questo la NASA ha sviluppato una
sonda da 600 kg ad altissima tecnologia
E ci ha chiesto di sviluppare un piccolo
satellite di nome Licia Cube che fosse
in grado rilasciato dalla sonda stessa
di prendere catturare delle immagini
dell'impatto stesso tra la sonda e
l'asteroide di morfos ma soprattutto di
riprendere quella che si chiama plum
ovvero i detriti fuoriusciti
dall'impatto stesso con queste immagini
la NASA avrebbe validato tutti i modelli
scientifici utilizzati per Il
dimensionamento della missione
e avrebbe determinato Le caratteristiche
morfologiche dell'asteroide dimorfos
considerata la richiesta sfidante NASA
stessa si aspettava anche solo una
immagine da dice Cube ero pienamente a
conoscenza del livello tecnologico dei
sistemi che avevamo in sviluppo nei
nostri laboratori Ma questa era una
richiesta gigante dovevamo progettare e
sviluppare testare assemblare un piccolo
satellite su una sonda della NASA in
meno di due anni Sapendo che Darth
sarebbe partito con o senza Licia Cube
avevo poco tempo il mio pensiero torna a
terra avevo davanti a me David che mi
guardava aspettando un mio segno una mia
reazione in quel momento mi sentivo
sorpreso ma lo sta chiedendo veramente
ma al tempo stesso preso da un senso di
di sfida Quindi vado a parlarne subito
con i miei colleghi all'interno del team
per raccontare la missione il nostro
contributo Ana questa missione
incredibile e mentre parlavo mentre
raccontava i dettagli perché vedevo
trasparire nella loro nel loro volto un
senso di dubbio di timore non era chiaro
come avremmo potuto far fronte a una
sfida del genere non abbiamo perso tempo
però abbiamo iniziato a fare il nostro
lavoro abbiamo fatto simulazione abbiamo
definito i primi
concetti di missione abbiamo scelto e
progettato la tecnologia per renderla
perfetta per una missione di questo
genere abbiamo anche concepito un
modello tridimensionale del satellite
felice Cube che ha mostrato la sua
faccia il suo volto un po' come
l'ecografia mostra le prime immagini di
un bimbo all'interno della pancia della
mamma è stato veramente un'emozione man
mano che andavamo avanti col progetto ci
si presentavano davanti tutte le sfide
tecnologiche
le criticità tecniche erano all'ordine
del giorno
alcune sembravano dei invalicabili dei
veri e propri showstopper e se stessimo
Tralasciando un dettaglio e se la
tecnologia che stiamo sviluppando
contenesse un errore ci guardavamo in
queste riunioni fiume
Sperando che qualcuno di noi alzasse la
mano e ci dicesse Ragazzi io la
soluzione vi do io la certezza che
questa tecnologia va bene per una
missione del genere ma sapevamo
perfettamente che nessuno mai l'aveva
sviluppata e quindi potevamo affittare
affidamento solo a noi stessi e alle
nostre capacità ancora ricordo uno di
quei giorni ero letteralmente disperato
perché non riuscivamo a trovare un
approccio ingegneristico verificabile
che avrebbe portato il satellite proprio
lì davanti all'asteroide dimorfos
esattamente nel momento dell'impatto con
la sonda d'arte sapevamo che rilasciati
dalla sonda questa manovra critica
Sarebbe dovuta essere operata in
pochissimi minuti
mantenendo sempre le camere quindi
sistemi ottici del satellite puntati
verso l'asteroide per evitare appunto di
perderci l'impatto Inoltre sapevamo che
visto che l'impatto sarebbe avvenuto a
circa 11 milioni di chilometri da terra
il segnale radio partendo da terra
arrivando a 11 milioni di chilometri e
tornando indietro ci avrebbe più o meno
impiegato più di un minuto quindi dei
tempi completamente incompatibili con
una manovra così breve non potevamo
quindi manovrare lì c'è Cuba da terra ma
Alice Cube avrebbe dovuto fare questa
manovra critica in completa autonomia
ora immaginatevi in una notte in cui
alzate gli occhi al cielo per ammirare
una stella e immaginate che tra voi la
stella ci sia un piccolo satellite
grande come una valigetta
in grado di operare in autonomia nel
vuoto e nel buio cosmico il diametro di
dimorfos è circa 160 metri più o meno
l'altezza della Mole Antonelliana quindi
è assimilabile a una Mole Antonelliana
per darvi l'idea del della manovra che
Licia che vi avrebbe dovuto fare
immaginate che sarebbe dovuta partire
dalla Sicilia puntando questo piccolo
telescopio
sempre verso la Mole Antonelliana quindi
di morfos e compiendo una traiettoria
che l'avrebbe Portata alla massima
prossimità con la steroide circa 55 km
dall'asteroide stesso più o meno la
distanza che ci separa da Cuneo a Torino
per poi terminare la manovra a Londra
per evitare che tutti i detriti
fuoriusciti dall'impatto distruggessero
il satellite quindi Sicilia Cuneo Londra
in meno di 15 minuti perché il satellite
sta volando a 7 chilometri al secondo
ovvero 25 mila chilometri orari no way
non ce l'avremmo mai fatta la sfida era
troppo alta in questi momenti mi sentivo
perso nel vuoto cosmico ed è stato
fondamentale proprio in questi momenti
ricevere una pacca sulla spalla e
sentirsi dire sbagliamo e impariamo
vedrete che ce la faremo non formule
segrete non equazioni matematiche ma una
semplice pacca sulla spalla Questo ci da
la fiducia ci dava la carica È come se
il problema scomparisse perché condiviso
con tutto il team con tutta l'azienda e
ci permetteva di ritornare Nei
laboratori a verificare il più possibile
con tutti i sistemi ionici che avevamo a
disposizione avevamo addirittura
sviluppato un simulatore che era in
grado di eseguire migliaia di
simulazione al giorno prendendo un
impasto delle rappresentazioni delle
immagini sintetiche di dimost e dimorfos
che c'erano state fornite dal nostro
partner scientifico L'Istituto nazionale
da astrofisica facevamo simulazioni
tutti i giorni per valutare i dettagli
ogni singolo possibile scenario di
emissione
ma avevamo sviluppato un algoritmo
basato sull'intelligenza artificiale in
grado di operare una manovra del tutto
autonoma e una tra le più veloci mai
eseguite sul satellite in orbita Il
satellite il progetto andava avanti il
liche Cube cominciava a materializzarsi
con l'arrivo il completamento dei
sistemi di volo abbiamo fatto tutte le
verifiche possibili le abbiamo
sottoposti a delle ciclature termiche
nel vuoto spinto per riprodurre
l'ambiente spaziale le abbiamo
sottoposti a delle prove di resistenza
alle radiazioni cosmiche gli abbiamo
installati su dei Banchi vibranti in
grado di riprodurre la stessa vibrazione
a cui sarebbe stato sottoposto il
satellite durante il lancio abbiamo poi
integrato tutti questi sistemi l'un
l'altro un propulsore a gas freddo due
sistemi ottici ad altissima risoluzione
è un computer di bordo in grado di
eseguire
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale in
tempo reale un sistema di alimentazione
invulnerabile alle radiazioni cosmiche
immaginate anche solo tutti i cavi
necessari per fare in modo che tutti
questi sistemi scambino informazioni e
potenze elettriche tutto questo
all'interno di questo piccolo satellite
Purtroppo non sono riuscito a
supportare e vedere la fase di
integrazione di Licia Cube perché fatta
dai miei colleghi nella camera Bianca
durante il periodo di covid Ma ricordo
perfettamente il momento in cui ho visto
per la prima volta Alice Cube dai vetri
della camera pulita Ero in piena
contemplazione l'avevamo realizzato il
sacrificio la voglia di voler
partecipare a questa missione
incredibile della NASA ci aveva portato
a raggiungere il primo risultato
straordinario
Ma era solo il primo Licia Cube Viene
spedita presso l'integration enproject
in facility
dell'astrofisic Club John Hopkins
University per iniziare tutte le
attività di integrazione sapevamo che
qualunque minimo errore qualunque svista
in questa fase avrebbe compromesso tutti
i risultati ottenuti fino a quel momento
pensate che avevamo proprio Durante la
fase di integrazione un monoblocco
d'alluminio un mattone d'alluminio della
stessa forma dimensioni e peso di liche
Cube che l'avrebbe che avrebbe preso il
nostro posto qualora qualunque cosa
fosse andata storta perché la missione
d'arte doveva volare la missione era
troppo importante per NASA Finalmente il
24 novembre 2022 Licia Cube integrata
nel con la sonda d'arte all'interno del
fairing del lanciatore Falcon 9 di
spacex viene lanciata
dalla base di lancio militare di
vanderberg in California ancora ricordo
la percezione avuta sulla pelle
trasmessa dalle vibrazioni al lancio
durante l'iniezione del motore lift-off
di questo bestione e pensavo Speriamo di
aver stretto bene tutte le viti il
viaggio di Alice Cube a bordo della
Sonda d'arte destinazione di morphos
dura circa 10 mesi e l'11 settembre 2022
viene rilasciata con successo a circa 14
milioni di chilometri da terra inizia
una prima fase che chiamiamo di
Commission in una fase in cui vengono
verificate tutte le funzionalità tutti
gli strumenti a bordo del satellite e
per vedere come operano nello spazio che
lo circonda quindi nello spazio profondo
è un po' come il bimbo fa quando fai i
suoi primi passi impara a conoscersi
Abbiamo scattato immagini delle Pleiadi
Abbiamo scattato immagini della terra
per calibrare gli strumenti ottici e per
essere sicuri e renderli operativi
proprio per effettuare quella manovra
critica lì quella che avrebbe portato
davanti a dimorfos all'impatto con la
sonda d'arte comunicavamo col satellite
attraverso il centro di controllo di
missione di Torino collegato a delle
antenne della Deep Space network di NASA
antenne giganti delle depressioni di
diametri dai 34 m ai 70 metri che
tipicamente vengono utilizzate per
supportare le missioni ai margini
dell'universo come ad esempio Voyager
dopo circa 14 giorni di commissioning
arriva il 25 settembre ora di pranzo
momento in cui mandiamo l'ultimo comando
al liceo Cube per augurarle buon lavoro
sapevamo che da quel momento in avanti
tutte le antenne sarebbero state puntate
verso d'arte per assistere il puntamento
e poi l'approccio in fine l'impatto con
l'asteroide avremmo poi ripristinato le
comunicazioni con licecube solo dopo due
ore dall'impatto la tensione saliva era
percettibile nel team arriva la notte
tra il 25 e il 26 settembre la NASA
inizia a mandare in diretta streaming
delle immagini favolose stupefacenti
dell'approccio all'asteroide da parte di
Dark erano delle immagini che solo a
guardarle sembrava di essere a bordo
della Sonda o in un videogioco
impatto avvenuto ora toccava a noi
[Musica]
vai che è dentro
ci ho fatto mettere
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Si vede che sono tenute
Wow
[Musica]
ragazzi al centro
ci avete visto giovani ingegneri alle
prese con una tecnologia nuova spaziale
mai sviluppata prima un team che
quotidianamente si è messo alla prova E
che giorno dopo giorno ha trasformato
tante piccole azioni ordinarie in un
qualcosa di straordinario credete sia
risultato straordinario per me lo
straordinario risiede in quel contributo
non richiesto quell'extra che ognuno di
noi ha voluto metterci per fare la
differenza il coraggio di provare una
volta in più quella giusta per riuscire
[Musica]